♪
>> SECRETARY MAYORKAS HAS
REFUSED TO ADDRESS THIS CRISIS,
BUT WE WON'T.
HE REGULARLY LIES TO THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE CLAIMING THAT
THE SOUTHERN BORDER IS CLOSED.
I HAVE BEEN THERE.
IT'S WIDE OPEN.
>> ALEJANDRO MAYORKAS HAS
FORESOWN HIS OATH TO PROTECT THE
HOMELAND.
>> I CAN PROMISE YOU TEXAS TEXAS
IS NOT GOING TO PUT UP WITH THIS
ANYMORE.
THIS REPUBLICAN LED CONGRESS
NEEDS TO HOLD ALEJANDRO MAYORKAS
ACCOUNTABLE.
HE NEEDS TO BE FIRED AND REMOVED
FROM OFFICE UNDER THE TOOLS OF
THE CONSTITUTION.
>> 20 HOUSE REPUBLICANS AND A
NUMBER OF BORDER OFFICIALS ARE
PUSHING TO RELEASE WILL
SECRETARY MAYORKAS AS WE ALREADY
LEARNED MORE THAN HALF A MILLION
MIGRANT ENCOUNTERS AT THE
SOUTHWEST BORDER SINCE OCTOBER.
>> CONGRESSMAN ANDY BIGS HOUSE
OVERSIGHT COMMITTEE AND IS
LEADING THE PUSH TO IMPEACH
MAYORKAS AND JOINS US NOW.
CONGRESSMAN, GOOD MORNING TO
YOU.
LET'S GET INTO SPECIFICS HERE.
ON WHAT GROUNDS ARE YOU CALLING
TO IMPEACH MAYORKAS?
HOW WOULD YOU GO ABOUT DOING
THIS?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, WE WILL
HAVE AN INVESTIGATION TO GO
THROUGH AND MAKE SURE THAT WE
ARE NOT RUSHING ON ANYTHING.
BUT, HERE'S THE DEAL.
IS HE VIOLATING TITLE 8.
TITLE 8 REQUIRES HIM TO HAVE --
MAINTAIN DETENTION OVER THESE
INDIVIDUALS UNTIL THEY HAVE HAD
THEIR IMMIGRATION STATUS
DETERMINED.
HE HAS SAID WE'RE GOING TO
RELEASE THEM.
IN FACT, THEY HAVE LEE LEASED
OVER A MILLION PEOPLE INTO THE
COUNTRY WHO ARE NOT HERE
LEGALLY.
HE HAS ALSO COMMITTED, WE THINK
HE HAS COMMITTED PERJURY, IT
LOOKS LIKE THAT.
HE HAS TOLD US THAT THE BORDER
IS OPERATIONALLY SECURE.
IT IS NOT TWO CRIMES RIGHT
THERE.
THEN YOU HAVE TWO ADDITIONAL
FACTS THAT HE HAS TOLD ICE THAT
WE'RE NOT GOING TO REMOVE PEOPLE
WHO ALREADY HAVE BEEN THROUGH
COURT, HAD DUE PROCESS.
THERE IS 1.2 MILLION OF THEM
THAT HAVE BEEN ORDERED TO BE
REMOVED.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO LOOK FOR
THEM.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO REMOVE THEM.
FOURTH THING IS HE HAS PROVIDED
INCENTIVES FOR PEOPLE TO COME
INTO THIS COUNTRY ILLEGALLY.
>> THE FIFTH THING IS HE HAS
PROVIDED SPECIFIC BREAKS FOR
CERTAIN COUNTRIES WHO SENT
MASSES OF PEOPLE HERE WHERE HE
HAS GONE AMP OTHER PEOPLE.
ALL OF THOSE THINGS INDICATE
THAT HE HAS COMMITTED HIGH
CRIMES AND MISDEMEANORS.
THAT'S THE STANDARD FOR
IMPEACHMENT.
>> Todd: CONGRESS, BEYOND
IMPEACHING MAYORKAS WHAT ARE
REPUBLICANS GOING TO DO WHEN
THEY TAKE OVER THE HOUSE NEXT
MONTH?
IN ORDER TO STEM THIS CRISIS?
DOES THAT INCLUDE WITHHOLDING
FUNDING?
DOES THAT INCLUDE INVESTIGATIONS
THAT LEAD TO SIGNIFICANT,
TANGIBLE CHANGES?
WHAT?
>> YEAH.
SO, THE WAY IT WOULD WORK IS IF
THIS OMNIBUS DOESN'T GET THROUGH
AND WE STILL HAVE A CHANCE TO
USE THE BUDGET AS LEVERAGE, WE
WILL LEVERAGE THE BUDGET TO MAKE
SURE THAT YOU FINISH THE WALL
AND YOU PROVIDE THE RESOURCES
NECESSARY TO THE BORDER PATROL
TO ENFORCE TITLE 8 AND YOU DON'T
DO AWAY WITH TITLE 42.
THOSE ARE ALL TOOLS TO STOP
WHAT'S GOING ON AT THE BORDER.
THE SECOND THING IS EXACTLY WHAT
YOU SAY.
YOU HAVE TO BRING PEOPLE IN AND
HOLD THEM ACCOUNTABLE TO THE
PUBLIC AND TO CONGRESS FOR THE
POLICIES THAT THEY DELIBERATELY,
INTENTIONALLY IT WILLFULLY PUT
INTO PLACE THAT ARE DRAWING
PEOPLE TO THIS COUNTRY AT THE
RATE OF LAST WEEKEND OVER 16,000
ENCOUNTERS.
AND THAT DOESN'T INCLUDE THE
GOT-AWAYS, WHICH THE TUCSON
SECTOR SOME DAYS IS OVER 1,000
PEOPLE KNOWN TO BE GETTING AWAY.
>> Carley: YEAH.
CONGRESSMAN, IN BOTH EL PASO AND
BROWNSVILLE, TWO CITIES THAT ARE
NOWHERE CLOSE TO EACH OTHER,
THOSE AREAS ARE SO OVERWHELMED
RIGHT NOW THAT BORDER PATROL IS
JUST MASS RELEASING MIGRANTS
OFFER OF THE STREETS.
AND THESE PEOPLE HAVE NOWHERE TO
GO.
THEY ARE ESSENTIALLY HOMELESS.
I REMEMBER UNDER THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION, DEMOCRATS WERE
INCENSED OVER THE LACK OF BEDS
THAT MIGRANTS HAD AT BORDER
PATROL FACILITIES.
SO, WHERE IS THAT OUTRAGE NOW?
>> WELL, THEY ARE MUTE ON THE
SUBJECT BECAUSE THEY SAY WE
CAN'T EVEN ADMIT THERE IS A
PROBLEM ON THE BORDER.
SOME OF THEM SAY IT'S ABSOLUTELY
OKAY.
THERE'S ONLY ONE DEMOCRAT THAT I
KNOW OF THAT IS TALKING ABOUT
THAT.
I MEAN, JUST TO YOUR POINT, THEY
ARE GOING TO START RELEASING
INTO THE COMMUNITY IN YUMA AS
WELL.
THEY HAVE A CITY THAT THEY PUT
UP, HOLDS 1200 PEOPLE BUT MOST
DAYS HAS OVER 3,000 PEOPLE.
ONLY ONE NGO, SMALL FACILITIES,
THE HOSPITAL THERE OVERRUN BY
PEOPLE BEING RELEASED INTO THE
COMMUNITY WHO JUST POP UP INTO
THE E.R. INTO THEIR MATERNITY
ROOM.
THIS IS GOING ON ALL ALONG THE
BORDER.
IT'S GOING TO BE SPREADING
THROUGHOUT THE ENTIRE COUNTRY.
IT HAS TO BECAUSE THERE IS JUST
MILLIONS OF PEOPLE THAT ARE
FLOODING THE BORDER.
>> Todd: WHEN YOU LOOK AT THESE
NUMBERS, THE IMAGES WE ARE
SEEING CURRENTLY ON OUR SCREEN
THESE ARE BAD BUT THIS IS BEFORE
TITLE 42 GOES AWAY.
IMAGINE HOW MUCH WORSE THIS IS
GOING TO ROOK WHEN THREE TIMES
MORE PEOPLE ARE COMING EVERY
DAY.  IT IS A FRIGHTENING
THOUGHT.
BEST OF LUCK TRYING TO SOLVE
THIS CRISIS CONGRESSMAN EAKD
BIGGS.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US THIS